welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast my name is Gus docker on this
episode I talk with Alan robach Ellen is
an atmospheric scientist at Rutgers
University and he was a member of the
intergovernmental panel on climate
change when it was awarded the Nobel
Peace Prize in 2007.
so on this episode we discussed the
science of nuclear winter we discuss
which places might be targeted in a
nuclear war
how International collaboration would
collapse during a nuclear winter and
then we also discuss whether it's wise
to prepare for nuclear winter by
researching geoengineering or food
production without sunlight
here's Alan robach
you have been researching nuclear window
for a number of decades now could you
tell us what is nuclear winter
nuclear winner is the climate change
that would result from a nuclear war
in a nuclear war cities and industrial
areas would be targeted and they would
burn producing lots of smoke which would
go up into the atmosphere
and Rise into the layer we call the
stratosphere which is above the layer
where we live and so
uh there's no rain there to wash it out
and it would last for years that would
absorb sunlight and it would get cold
and dark and dry at the Earth's surface
and if there was enough smoke
temperatures could get below freezing
even in the summertime and that's why we
call it nuclear winter
and this work is mostly built on
computer simulations if I understand it
correctly is that true
well yeah we can't actually do the
experiment the real world
so we use computer models that have been
tested with other things like volcanic
eruptions and forest fires
and then we use natural analogs to test
parts of the theory
what information do we gain from these
volcanic eruptions and forest fires
volcanic eruptions every once in a while
produce clouds in the stratosphere too
and they reflect sunlight and make it
colder at the Earth's surface after
large eruptions there have been
significant coolings in 1815 the Tambora
eruption in Indonesia produced a cloud
that went around the world and in 1816
It produced A Year Without a summer it
was there was snow every month in the
summer in New England in the United
States and so this cooling which lasted
about a year caused famine in the United
States in Europe and in China so this is
a natural example of what we think would
happen to uh even greater extent after
nuclear war these volcanic eruptions
they are kind of natural equivalents to
what would happen in the case of a
nuclear war causing a nuclear winter so
the the greatest harm would come from
agricultural collapse is that correct
yeah well if nuclear weapons were used
the Direct effects would be horrific of
course we know what would happen because
of the examples during the first nuclear
war 77 years ago when the U.S attacked
Hiroshima and Nagasaki there will be
blasts there would be fires and there
would be radioactivity and that would be
horrible but we've calculated that more
than 10 times as many people would die
in areas far removed from the uh from
the attack than from the Direct effects
calculating the probability of a nuclear
war is uh above my pay grade I I don't
know how to do that we don't have any
data there's been one nuclear war in the
history of the world and there hasn't
been any haven't been any for more than
75 years now so the question is what
could actually start another nuclear war
the first thing is the existence of
nuclear weapons means that they can be
used so if we get rid of nuclear weapons
then we can't have a nuclear war and
that's the
ultimate solution because they really
can't be used in any logical way
they could be used by accident
by
misreading of sensors there have been
several cases where countries thought
they were under attack and they almost
launched a nuclear war where it was
either a computer malfunction or human
error the U.S Secretary of Defense was
woken up in the middle of the night once
from people in Colorado saying we're
under attack wake up the president and
it turned out they'd put a training tape
in rather than the actual one and they
thought they were they thought it was a
real Attack
the the Russians thought that they were
being attacked when Norway launched the
sounding rocket then and it was from the
direction of the United States Norway
had informed the Russians they were
going to do that but the communication
got lost and they thought they were
under attack another time a Russian
system thought five missiles are on the
way and the officer in charge status
left petroff said
you know I built that system that that
looks kind of funny I know my orders are
too warn uh the the hierarchy to start a
war but if they attacked why would it
only be five missiles and it turned out
it was reflection off of clouds that
they were sensing so there are all kinds
of scenarios that we know about and I'm
sure there are a lot that we don't know
about that could have almost started a
nuclear war
there are now nine nations with nuclear
weapons there was just one the United
States and then and then the Soviet
Union and then England France and China
those are the called the P5 the
permanent members of the security
Council and now for more Nations have
nuclear weapons India Pakistan North
Korea and Israel although Israel won't
admit it so
about 15 17 years ago we started
thinking about
well some of these new nations they
don't have that many weapons but what if
they had a nuclear war what would that
do to the to the climate and so we
calculated the effects of an
india-pakistan nuclear war because at
the time
due to their continuing skirmishes along
the kashmiri border some of which
actually ended up in fighting we thought
that might be the most likely way that a
nuclear war could start
and India and Pakistan compared to the
U.S and Russia they don't have a lot of
of nuclear weapons but still the effects
from a from a nuclear war between them
could be horrific so could you tell us
about the the simulation of of a nuclear
war between India and Pakistan
when we started doing this work again
looking at India Pakistan each country
had about a hundred nuclear weapons and
the easiest one to make are a uranium
bomb like the US dropped on Hiroshima
just two pieces of uranium get put
together and that makes a critical mass
and it explodes it doesn't require a lot
of high technology and and the explosive
power of that bomb was about 15 kilotons
equivalent of 15 000 tons of TNT so we
assumed that these were the size that
they had and the scenario we used was
each of them used half of their nuclear
weapons to attack the other country so
100 Hiroshima sized nuclear weapons
and then we calculate how much smoke
would be generated by cities birding in
each Country and we got more than six
million tons of smoke
to uh simplify it I I just calculated
five million tons of smoke so really
that would be only like 85 uh weapons
and so my student Luke Oman was studying
volcanic eruptions and we had computer
model to do that and we put that much
smoke in and calculated the climate
response
and we were surprised it wouldn't
produce nuclear winter that as
temperatures wouldn't get below freezing
in the summertime but it would cool the
Earth to temperatures colder than the
little ice age in fact it would be uh
climate change greater than ever before
experienced in recorded human history
this smoke we're talking about what type
of smoke is this well we just use black
carbon uh soot uh pure black carbon and
in the real world uh when you burn
something if you can smell smoke then
that's not the carbon that's the
unburned organic material that that
sometimes can coat the smoke and so
we're in the process now trying to do a
more realistic calculation of exactly
what the chemistry of the smoke would be
and how it would be affected as it goes
up into the in the stratosphere
another another analog we use is is
large forest fires so in our model the
smoke goes into the lower Stratosphere
the sunlight hits it its black so it
absorbs sunlight and gets heated and
then it rises farther up into the
atmosphere to the upper Stratosphere and
that's what makes it last for years and
blow around the world
but we have reason to believe that in an
actual nuclear war cities would be
attacked and so we would actually get
the bad kind of smoke from the burning
of urban and industrial areas
that's right the military claims that
they only target military targets they
claims we don't Target civilians per se
in fact the law of War prohibits it
although I'm not sure if there's anybody
available to enforce that law and
certainly after nuclear war there
wouldn't be
but it turns out that there are a lot of
military Targets in cities in the U.S
there's this funny five-sided building
in Washington DC
I think I remember that uh there were
over a hundred Targets in Moscow that
the U.S considers military targets
I had The Surreal experience of meeting
Fidel Castro twice who invited me down
to Cuba to talk about nuclear winter and
he explained that during the Cuban
Missile Crisis they took their air they
when the U.S was going to uh potentially
attack they distributed their airplanes
to lots of different Regional airports
around the country so they couldn't all
be hitting in in one place because they
had the example of that happening in in
other Wars so there would be
you know the US and Russia each have
thousands of nuclear weapons and we
can't find that many Targets in each
country so in the 1980s when we
calculated nuclear winter when their
arsenals were much bigger
we put uh
we only used a third of each Arsenal and
we put one Target on every possible one
weapon at every possible Target in each
country and then there was still this
huge pile of weapons
well all right let's put two on in case
the first one doesn't work and there was
still a huge problem turns out there
were nine weapons for every Target
that is an astonishing fact why why did
the the US and Russia build so many
nuclear weapons that's that's the
question that I've often wondered what
what's the Strategic importance of
having thousands upon thousands of
nuclear warheads and why do they still
have that many all the other countries
with nuclear weapons have a couple
hundred the US and Russia still have
thousands well I don't think it makes
any military sense in fact we have uh a
Triad we have uh land-based missiles we
have bombs that go on to
airplanes and we have submarine-based uh
ballistic missiles and
why do we need all of those in fact the
land-based missiles are very
destabilizing because the Russians know
where they are if they're being attacked
they have to be launched within a few
tens of minutes or they'll be destroyed
and so the president has to make a
decision very quickly and uh what if
they aren't really being attacked what
if it's a false alarm are they going to
be starting a nuclear war and so one of
the
quickest things we could do to make the
world safer is to take those off of a
hair trigger alert and then get rid of
them what we don't need them we can't
use them in fact if we ever think using
nuclear weapons is a good idea we can
use a invulnerable submarine-based
missiles and we don't have to do it
really quickly
I think it comes down to money and power
that's why that's why we have so many uh
there are huge multi-net huge
corporations that make lots of money
building nuclear weapons there are
military people whose careers are based
on controlling these nuclear weapons and
they don't want to give that up in fact
when the new Star treaty was signed 10
years ago by President Obama and
president Medvedev to get it approved by
the U.S Senate which requires a
two-thirds vote
Obama promised them a modernization of
our nuclear Arsenal and unfortunately
that's still going on so the US is
planning to spend more than a trillion
dollars to build new missiles to replace
the ones that we already have that still
work new new submarines new airplanes
and they can't be used so it's it's a
huge sink of money that could be used
for much more useful things like giving
for example vaccines there to everybody
in the world or health care so uh I I
think it's it's uh and they make so much
money they have armies of lobbyists
going into to uh give money to
congressmen and to
use fear as a as a as a weapon we think
people think if we have if we have more
weapons than they do or they have more
weapons than we do that that that's a
problem and so
but
that's not always what's happened in
history where the Soviet Union was
falling apart in fact when President
Obama was President I was at an American
geophysical union meeting and his
nuclear advisor Rose gottmuller was
there talking about detection of
underground tests and after her talk I
went up to her and said you know
why doesn't President Obama reduce our
nuclear arsenal we have way more than we
need we can't use them we don't need a
tree to reduce oh no no we can't do that
and I don't think she even understood
the question but when the Soviet Union
was falling apart in the early 1990s
President George H.W bush unilaterally
reduced our Arsenal and later on the
Soviets followed and so uh it can be
done President Obama got the Nobel Peace
Prize but he didn't really do anything
about reducing our nuclear Arsenal in
some senses it's easier in our country
for a Republican
president to do it because they're not
considered soft on defense somehow uh
although that's a whole other
conversation but we could easily reduce
our Arsenal if I mean I when I give a
talk I say how many if you think nuclear
weapons are a deterrence to an attack
how many would you have to put onto the
capital city of your enemy to deter them
from attacking us
and usually the answer is one
and so I said yeah so so maybe we need
two in case the first one doesn't work
so a couple hundred is more than enough
why do we need thousands and so it
doesn't make sense when you really need
some enlightened leadership to to do
this and I was hoping President Biden
would do that he was known to say in the
past that we should reduce our Arsenal
but the uh they just did a new review of
our nuclear policy it hasn't been
released yet but as I understand it it
doesn't really include any reduction of
our nuclear Arsenal or or stopping the
the modernization
so when you when you say we can't use
these weapons what is it that you mean
there is it simply that we have so many
that we that's or that the U.S has so
many nuclear weapons that using all of
them would would destroy life on Earth
yeah uh people think of deterrence as
Mutual assured destruction so if you
attack me I'm going to attack you so
that's why you have to not do it well
Brian toon and I wrote a paper called
self-assured destruction what if one
country the us or Russia attacked the
other and the other one didn't do
anything back
everybody in the country that did the
attacking would die from starvation
because of the climate response so it
would be like you're acting like a
suicide bomber for deterrence to work
you have to believe people are willing
to kill themselves it's completely crazy
and and people
just ignore that when they when they uh
talk about deterrence so nuclear winter
changes the logic of nuclear deterrence
yes and nuclear deterrence also means
that uh for it to work it has to work
perfectly forever what if there's a
mistake what if uh
uh there's a a an accidental uh use of
nuclear weapons so
you know as we talk uh President Putin
threatened uh to take his put his
nuclear weapons on on high alert when uh
soon after the Ukrainian Invasion which
wasn't going his way
there was no evidence that anything
changed actually in Russia it was just
words but it really shocked people that
somebody might consider using nuclear
weapons
so what if one nuclear weapon was
actually used
what would happen then
would the rest of the world recall
recoil and horror and not do anything or
would some
uh
Battlefield Commander somewhere decide
that well we've got to RE reply in kind
there's certainly the danger of
escalation
and it could result in a global nuclear
war so I I hope that our warnings about
nuclear winter which started in the
1980s have permeated uh people's
knowledge enough so that I that people
are worried about that and that sort of
maybe uh serving some thing of a
deterrence
in the 1980s at a rush an American team
turkotune Ackerman Pelican Sagan and a
Russian team Alexander from stencikov
both calculate what will be the climate
response to a nuclear war and both of
them got nuclear winter
I did a paper the next year uh uh
reinforcing that and this information
was given to both presidents Reagan and
Gorbachev
and because it came from scientists on
both sides they trusted it and both of
them said we're ending our arms race
because we're worried about nuclear
winter the nuclear war cannot be won and
must never be fought they agreed on that
statement a couple years later and so
it really felt powerful to actually have
science in foreign policy there were
also
Mass anti-nuclear demonstrations in
Democratic countries like the UK and the
U.S that helped
so right now so the number of weapons
started to go down the arms race went uh
went away but still there are thousands
and thousands of nuclear weapons in the
arsenals of the US and Russia the
problem isn't solved even today's
Arsenal's can produce nuclear winter
I'm thinking that many people will die
from the Direct effects of drug nuclear
weapons and many people will die from
the agricultural collapse but could
there also be further effects of say
that there's an agricultural collapse
and this destabilizes the world or
decreases International cooperation do
you do you foresee what we could call
second order effects from nuclear winter
well that's really not my area of
expertise but I can
we've analyzed how much food there would
be available in each country based on
how the climate would change and how
each crop would respond to the cold
temperatures less sunlight less less
water
and our
default scenario involves no more trade
in agriculture each country would start
hoarding what they have
in our country two years ago there was
no toilet paper to be found people were
hoarding toilet paper so they're uh this
year when uh India uh started stopped
exporting their their wheat uh because
of uh of uh drought and they didn't have
enough uh and so there are in 2010 there
was a drought and heat wave in Russia
they stopped exporting wheat in the
price of food doubled in the Middle East
and that was uh part of a trigger for
the Arab Spring and so we already have
examples of hoarding of stopping trade
when people have shortages and so in
such a dire situation most of the world
would have no Direct effects of nuclear
war they'd just see maybe the sky
getting darker but there wouldn't be any
bombs dropped in them but they would all
go to the library read our articles and
understand that uh they're gonna have
trouble growing food next year and so
they would keep what they have and and
which do you want to do make a little
bit more money selling it or have enough
food to eat and so that was our default
scenario that there would be no
International Trade the complicated the
complications of that whether there
would be even within a country would
certain groups get a lot more food than
other groups uh that requires further
analysis and so we need to get other
people who are experts in that to work
on that of course it's a simplifying
assumption that there will be no
international trade in food but there is
some justification for thinking that
there would at least be a steep decline
in decline in international trade
because politicians political leaders in
each country is directly responsible for
the voters of that country and so you
could you could easily see how food
shortages around the world would would
have a kind of a nationalizing inward
looking effect on on nation states yeah
even in countries that don't have voters
even in dictatorships even in the in
dictatorships political leaders are in
some sense responsible to the population
they can be overthrown they can be
harmed if they if they if the population
becomes too unhappy yeah fairness has
resulted in a number of revolutions
diplomacy and international cooperation
is notorious notoriously tricky and
difficult to make work so I'm interested
in exploring options for what could be
done
if it goes wrong so kind of thinking
about what we could do to prepare for a
nuclear winter if it happens I think
that's a terrible idea if you think we
can prepare for a nuclear winter that
increases the probability of it
happening
I think people are afraid now that the
use of nuclear weapons could expand into
a global nuclear war and it would be a
catastrophe for everybody on the planet
and that's what the will of the people
that's what the band treaty says and is
worried about if you think you can
survive it if you're going to have
enough uh potatoes and
fungus you grow on trees in the dark and
and uh other distribution mechanisms
then then why worry about it uh then I
think that re that uh reduces the
pressure not to have a nuclear war I'm
saying we should do both I think it
would be prudent to do both to both
attempt to do everything we can
diplomatically and politically to to
prevent nuclear winter from happening
but also prepare in the event of a
disaster the global average amount of
food stored is about two months Supply
so it's really grow it and then eat it
transport it and eat it so uh to
store enough food for years for because
a nuclear winter the climate response
would be about five six seven years of
of cooling then gradually it would warm
up and so you need years worth of
agricultural production you'd have to be
prepared for it okay
let's talk about or touch upon at least
geoengineering which is another research
interest of yours yeah so normally when
we talk about geoengineering we're or at
least how I think of it is as a last
resort against climate change where you
begin or when you when you try to block
out sunlight from reaching the surface
of the Earth for example by by creating
artificial clouds
um could we do sort of reverse
geoengineering aimed at increasing
sunlight on the surface of the Earth in
the case of a nuclear winter
I've heard of a couple papers have been
written uh to try and quickly warm up
Earth but that not that's not the way
that it would that they have suggested
uh if there's a big volcanic eruption it
would cause
a huge amount of cooling I mean there
have been super volcanic eruptions that
cause several degrees of cooling for
several years
uh so the idea is to develop these
short-lived greenhouse gases
that absorb heat leaving Earth and
radiate it downward and cause warming
but they would you know CO2 has a
lifetime of of decades uh that and so
you don't want to release more carbon
dioxide but in theory you could design
gases which are Super absorbers but only
have a lifetime of a year or two and you
could stockpile them in tanks around the
world it doesn't much matter where they
are because they would get distributed
by the winds and if you get this massive
cooler you could just release them and
they would absorb heat and warm it back
up uh at the same time scale that the
smoke or the or the volcanic uh
particles would dissipate they would
they would uh come apart at the same
time
so that's that's a that's a theory
that's a theory a theoretical uh study
such gases don't exist and but in theory
perhaps you could invent them
but then it would be trillions of
dollars to to uh manufacture them and to
store them and to keep them from leaking
and and
keep it ready for a disaster that might
never happen and so again I think that's
probably if you think that that would
work and then you have to worry about
nuclear winter I think that would be a
terrible idea because it would increase
the probability of people using nuclear
weapons
I definitely take your point that this
could happen but I I think we we can we
can be very worried about nuclear winter
while simultaneously attempting to
prepare for for it in the worst case no
the way to get rid of nuclear winter is
to get rid of nuclear weapons and it's
very simple uh there's only a few
hundred a few thousand nuclear weapons
in the world it's it's a much simpler
problem to solve than global warming
because it's not the fundamental basis
of our energy Supply it's not
retrofitting everybody to drive an
electric car and with windmills and and
stuff it's it's it's uh it's not
changing a huge infrastructure it's just
turning off things and uh so during the
1980s there were like 70 000 nuclear
weapons in the world and now there's
only about uh thirteen thousand so
where'd all those weapons go we know how
to we know how to take them apart we
know how to dilute the the radioactive
part we know how to actually use it as
fuel for nuclear power reactors we know
how to do that is very very easy to do
and so it's not doesn't require any new
technology to get rid of them and to
dismantle them I think you're right that
it would be more or it would be easier
to tackle than to than tackling a
climate change
um
yeah okay let's talk about your
experience working on on nuclear winter
throughout the decades uh if nuclear
Windsor as a theory has faced a lot of
skepticism how has it been dealing with
this skepticism
in the so 1982 I think I went to
American geophysical union meeting and I
saw there was a paper uh talking to be
given the climatic effects of nuclear
war and I thought
that's curious wonder what that's about
and I went to the talk and it was
canceled because the people that were
going to give it were some of them were
for NASA NASA Ames Research lab and the
director of the lab said you can't work
on nuclear war if NASA headquarters sees
us working on nuclear war I will hurt
our funding and so they said
all right what are we going to call this
and they ended up with the term nuclear
winter which was uh brilliant because it
was the cause and effect in two words
and it's it's it's caught on but that
alerted me to what the idea was and
there was a meeting in Washington DC at
the Shoreham Hotel the next year just
before the tax paper was released and
they was one of the first International
satellite telecoms so there was a group
in Moscow and a group in Washington
participate at the same time and the
Russians and the Americans presented
their results
and I said you know I've been working on
volcanic eruptions I can use the climate
model I'm using to look at the effects
of smoke from nuclear war and I wrote a
paper that was published in nature the
next year and was part of the team that
was that was warning the world about
about nuclear winter and then as I
mentioned uh Gorbachev and and uh Reagan
ended the arms race and credited nuclear
winter
research is as one of the reasons they
did that so how did that moment feel to
you by the way it felt wonderful uh uh I
I what do I do what do you do with the
rest of your life now that you've solved
the problem of nuclear weapon
and but as you mentioned there was
skepticism some people said well you
know these models are very simple I
don't believe them and then there was uh
some scientists who like Steve Schneider
who did some calculations and found with
a more sophisticated model that climate
change one isn't as large and called it
nuclear fall even though he knew that
would be misinterpreted but at the time
uh
it was kind of easy to predict what the
climate what the climate the result of
the science was from scientists based on
what their politics were the
conservative ones said it's not true and
the the the Livermore liberal one said
it is true and so a lot of people did
calculations and I did studies of forest
fire smoke to see how it cooled the
Earth and none of the work uh
uh said that nuclear winter was wrong
the the fundamental physics is very
simple if you block out sunlight it gets
colder and I mentioned analogues before
we have other analogs like the seasons
it's colder in Winter because there's
less sunlight the days are shorter and
the sun's at a lower angle it's colder
at night because there's no sun so we we
have these fundamental analogs we know
that and and the fundamental question is
how much smoke and how long does it last
at the time the
computers that were available were like
these super computers uh like a credit
snipper computer but my my iPhone is or
is it magnitude more powerful than than
those it has more storage and faster
computation so uh
but still nuclear winner there was a
National Academy of Sciences study by
the U.S national Academy that went over
all the studies and said yes nuclear
winner is is a valid Theory and that
sort of put it to rest and then
as I said uh 15 17 years ago we started
working on this again and we calculated
uh the effects of a war between India
and Pakistan using a modern computer
model that runs on a a standard computer
now not even a super computer and we we
had enough competing power to do
simulations not for 20 days like was
done back then but for 10 years and we
put smoke in we also had a model that
would have the smoke be heated lofted
into the stratosphere blown around the
world and and fall out years later and
so we did that calculation and we found
yes nuclear winner we still get nuclear
winter in the center of continence and
so uh we went back and did the nuclear
winter the U.S Russia case as well as
india-pakistan case
uh then five years ago
thanks to a conversation I had with a
program manager at the open philanthropy
project we were able to get funded to
continue this work we were sort of doing
it on the side without without uh much
funding but we now have substantial
funding we've done a lot of work in the
last five years with a team with Brian
tune at University of Colorado and me
leading it and we've had other
scientists working with us and we've
used these state-of-the-art computer
model from the national Center for
atmospheric research and redid the
nuclear winter simulation for U.S Russia
and we got almost exactly the same
result as we got from the NASA model
from 15 years ago which was lower
resolution had less physics in it so
that's pretty sure if you put smoke in
the atmosphere we're pretty sure what
the climate response would be the
fundamental question is still how much
smoke another question people ask is
well so we've tested nuclear weapons
many times in the atmosphere before
testing stopped why was there no nuclear
winter well the tests were done in the
desert or out over the ocean where there
was nothing to burn so it's the smoke
from the fires that causes the climate
change not the bomb itself the people
all the scientists who ran these nuclear
tests were they aware of of were they
consciously trying to prevent smoke from
from being caused by by these nuclear
explosions or could they have kind of
accidentally set off a nuclear winter
well I I think that they uh did tests
where they tried not to kill people and
try to be in remote areas unfortunately
some of the tests in the Pacific
produce so much radioactivity that the
cloud drifted over islands where there
were people and caused terrible death
and and radioactive damage uh in in
Bikini Atoll for example and Japanese
fishing boats and so but that wasn't
intentional they were trying to keep it
away from where people that's why the
first uh test of the plutonium bomb in
in Alamogordo in New Mexico and White
Sands was out in the middle of a desert
where there was nobody around so it
wasn't that they were
trying to prevent smoke they're trying
to not do it where there was anything to
to be destroyed you mentioned that at
some point you had problem getting
funding for This research which is in a
sense quite shocking here you have a a
plausible causal mechanism that could
harm billions of people and you still
are unable to get the right amount of
funding for it do you think that we are
that Humanity as a whole is just
doomed to not focus on the right issues
yes uh in the 1980s
I was able to get some funding for two
years from the defense nuclear agency
which is now called ditra they I think
they figured that you know this is a
theory from a bunch of left-wing College
professors and we throw enough money at
it we'll find the flaw in it but the
more work we did the stronger their
Theory got the more sure we were that
was true and then they stopped funding
us
so we didn't give them the answer they
wanted we did we reported the science
that we found
I've been funded by National Science
Foundation for many years to study the
effects of volcanic eruptions on climate
and I studied them as an analog to
nuclear winter and so I sort of did a
little of this on the side but we really
didn't have enough money and it was
actually the open philanthropy called me
to for some advice on funding a uh
geoengineering project
and after I talked to the program
manager Claire zabel I said would you
consider funding uh work on nuclear
winter we've asked the National Science
Foundation we've asked the defense
department who has the bombs we've asked
the department of energy that makes the
bombs of ask the Department of Homeland
Security whose job it is to to protect
us from nuclear weapons we've even asked
the intelligence Service uh can you give
us some funding to say this and nobody
we couldn't find a program manager that
would that would fund it they uh
Homeland Security said well if you want
to study a terrorist dropping a bomb in
New York City and where the
radioactivity would go we would we would
fund that the military said well you
know
we'll we'll fund you to study uh uh
climate change you know every did you
know that every Naval Base is at sea
level and so sea level rise is a problem
we want to study that or ice melting but
this no we won't fund it we couldn't
find a program manager she said well
okay uh send us a
I'm not sure what that is send me a
proposal so Brian toon and I sat down
and we said
what would we do we would calculate the
uh how much smoke there would be would
burn cities for the first time model
that would calculate clown response
would try to include the agricultural
response and we had a rather audacious
budget we thought of a million dollars
for three years and we sent that to her
and she said well okay send us a bigger
proposal we'll send that for review and
if you need more money ask for more
money uh we want you to be sure you have
enough to get it done so
most program managers say can you cut
the budget but so we put in 2.98 million
dollars uh in this budget and win six
different pieces and we said if you want
to fund any of these it would be great
and within a couple months I said okay
here's your three million dollars
that was the only time I ever had
experience like that uh to give you more
money than you asked for in a much
shorter period of time and we were very
productive and three years later we
asked for Renewal we got another three
million dollars and so a million dollars
a year so we're funding groups at
Colorado and and and Rutgers and and uh
Columbia University I can ask what are
we hoping to to find out with this
increased level of funding we still need
to know exactly what happens when a city
Burns there we have high resolution
models of forest fire uh forest fires
and forest fire propagation but we need
to know what the fuel is in every city
and so how much material is there to
burn and uh and does it matter if more
modern buildings are made more of stone
or
uh or of Steel rather than of wood or is
it the contents that burned it's really
the contents that burn the fires last
for hours not the brick building itself
Burns and so and we so we're working on
that we have a team working on that and
we then we need to work on what happens
to
if if agriculture is is reduced how
would Society respond in terms of
uh economics in terms of trade within a
country and between countries how would
this availability of food change over
time in detail so that we need a lot
more work on that there's a sociological
or economic research aspect to this
problem also yes
we we uh we wrote one paper on the
economics with an economist at Rutgers
but it just sort of scratched the
surface so uh the problem with economics
is that uh
human behavior is a lot more complicated
than the climate system we have
equations that describe how the climate
system works we have conservation of
energy conservation and momentum and we
can calculate how the climate will
change there's chaos of course built in
so you can't do weather forecasting
Beyond a couple weeks but we can do
multiple runs with different uh initial
conditions and get a statistical
representation of the climate and we
test these models every day by doing
weather forecasts and we do climate
model simulations of past climate change
we know what cause causes where we know
what happened we can model volcanic
eruptions we can model forest fires so
so we're pretty confident in that but
human behavior in groups of humans are
really complicated I mean who would have
predicted the war in Ukraine uh having
huge massive changes to
to uh the world food supply for example
how do you how do you predict uh
[Music]
human behavior and how people would
behave and and so that's more difficult
but we do need them to work on that as
best they can
Alan thank you for talking with me it's
been very interesting thanks very much
and I hope the publicity about this will
help people to realize how dangerous
nuclear weapons are